[Música]
para hablar del cambio climático los
cambios provocados por el hombre en la
naturaleza así como los crímenes que se
cometen contra la biodiversidad como la
deforestación el cambio de uso del suelo
la producción la agrícola y también la
ganadera intensiva o el creciente
comercio ilegal de la vida silvestre
esto puede acelerar y acelerar el ritmo
de la destrucción de nuestro planeta
según la organización de naciones unidas
hoy 22 de abril y cuando se celebra el
día de la tierra nos damos cuenta que
necesitamos un cambio urgente inmediato
hacia una economía más sostenible que
funcione tanto para las personas como
para nuestro planeta por supuesto porque
sin él no existimos además del servicio
de cambio climático de la unión europea-
copernicus presentó su quinta edición
del informe anual con conclusiones poco
alentadoras el viejo continente sufrió
el verano más caluroso en el registro de
2021 un año que vino acompañado por
múltiples desastres naturales desde
incendios inundaciones e intensas olas
de calor las concentraciones de gases de
efecto invernadero causa el
calentamiento global fueron mayores que
en cualquier otro momento en el planeta
en al menos dos millones de años y para
ello entonces para hablar de lo que
ocurre y lo que estamos haciendo
nosotros por qué problema somos nosotros
a nuestro planeta quiero saludar
entonces en este momento nuestro segundo
invitado al dial es ricardo quiroga del
centro de investigación langley de la
nasa coordinadora del programa de
desastres de la nasa gracias ricardo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francia 24 cuando la gente piensa en la
nasa la mayoría piensa en la exploración
de nuestro espacio pero cuál es la
relación de la nasa con el día de la
tierra
bueno muy buenos días es un honor estar
aquí con todos ustedes
la nasa tiene tres divisiones grandes
exploración del espacio profundo
búsqueda de vida en otros planetas pero
la mayor cantidad de observaciones de la
tierra que hace la masa las hace sobre
nuestro planeta tierra que es nuestra
casa y ese es el objetivo principal de
la división de ciencias aplicadas de la
tierra de la nasa en la cual yo trabajo
riccardo hoy se celebra el día 52 de la
tierra que ha transcurrido que ha
ocurrido en nuestro planeta durante todo
este tiempo que cambios observados la
nasa en estas últimas cinco décadas no
porque abajo ustedes tienen estas
imágenes satelitales espectaculares y
ahí se pueden dar cuenta del cambio y el
daño que le hemos hecho nosotros al
planeta
si las variables son los signos vitales
del planeta han venido cambiando la nasa
tiene 21 misiones satelitales con
diferentes tipos de sensores viendo la
variable planeta como humedad
temperatura del suelo en temperatura del
océano variables atmosféricas lo que
hemos visto durante las últimas décadas
es efectivamente una demostración
científica del incremento de 1.1 grados
centígrados promedio en el planeta y
esto hace que en algunos lugares haya
sido mayor en otro lugares ha sido menor
la concentración de gases de efecto
invernadero estamos alrededor de 417 421
partes por millón de dióxido de carbono
la pérdida de los glaciares hemos
perdido un 13% de los glaciares en
staten en esta época también está
científicamente demostrado y esto hace
que nos enfrentemos a escenarios de
mayores amenazas naturales he combinado
con factores sociales se conviertan en
desastres ahora ricardo cómo afecta todo
este trabajo relacionada con las
ciencias y la tierra que realizan nasa
por ejemplo a nuestra comunidad
bueno
la nasa
hay que decirlo tiene todos los datos
son gratis abiertos y disponibles para
toda la humanidad la nasa es un
proveedor de datos de origen satelital
de
alta mediana y resolución gruesa lo que
permite es que los tomadores de
decisiones a nivel regional local puedan
tener herramientas para tomar decisiones
por ejemplo tenemos un sensor que está
viendo los dos puntos de calor de donde
hay incendios y con esta información
sabiendo dónde están los incendios se
puedan tomar decisiones para mitigarlos
para controlarlos y también otras
variables para reducir el riesgo de este
tipo de desastres el la nasa como
proveedor de datos le permite a la
humanidad contar con información de alta
confiabilidad para la toma de decisiones
en términos de cambio climático y
ordenamiento territorial y desastres
claro ricard también tengo entendido que
la nasa tiene varias misiones de ciencia
de la tierra este año tiene alguna que
le entusiasme usted muchísimo más que
otra bueno me entusiasma particularmente
la misión nai saber que es una misión es
el radar de apertura sintética de la
nasa que va a ser lanzado el año el año
que viene con una resolución de 7 metros
y esto nos va a permitir contar con una
cantidad de datos muy interesantes para
gestionar los bosques para gestionar las
coberturas terrestres para mirar la
evolución en comportamiento de los
volcanes y mirar inundaciones tiene una
gran cantidad de aplicaciones y está
misión para mí es particularmente
emocionante sobre todo porque mi rol
está enfocado a la reducción del riesgo
de desastres en las américas donde
podemos obtener más información de las
actividades la nasa hoy 22 de abril
cuando celebramos el día de la tierra de
ricardo bueno básicamente ir al sitio
web nasa tiene distintos sitios web pero
pueden ir a www
y aquí ahí pueden encontrar toda una
puerta abierta al universo de datos de
la nasa modelaciones
imágenes datos para la comunidad
científica en la comuna en general allí
está toda nuestra información
claro ricardo también tengo otra
pregunta digamos con todos estos datos y
todas estas imágenes que ustedes
recaudan como la organi nasa se ha
prevenido realmente estos desastres
naturales hemos podido tener como mayor
visión de lo que va a pasar en un futuro
como han servido todos estos datos para
nuestro uso para el uso de la humanidad
en nuestro beneficio también de nuestro
planeta para para cuidarlo más
claro efectivamente la información en la
reducción de riesgo de desastres tiene
diferentes etapas una de ellas el
monitoreo de las variables del planeta
los signos vitales del planeta en tiempo
cercano al real y podemos ver los
incendios en una ventana de 6 horas de
que hayan ocurrido
y la lluvia la podemos ver en la ventana
de 5 minutos 30 minutos y de ahí en
adelante diferentes obras los mismos los
vientos la temperatura del océano y esto
permite a las autoridades a los
gobiernos ya los científicos tomar
decisiones de una manera mucho más
oportuna y con una información mucho más
acertada decisiones más informadas y
efectivamente se ha avanzado bastante la
reducción de residuos de desastres ya no
estamos como hace muchos años los
desastres llegaban y no sabíamos
exactamente el impacto ahora ya tenemos
mucha mejor información para tomar
decisiones y eso ayuda a salvar vidas
bienes infraestructura y de alguna
manera a mitigar el impacto que un
desastre gigante pueda tener sobre la
economía del país